tar
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
it's written in death note that criminals will die 3 weeks ahead but
it also shows that kira can control
my time
so this  In case I don't have any information
, it's fine if the newly reported criminal dies
.
No matter how you look at it, I'm pretending to be a student who's studying in preparation I
'm a criminal who's been in the news
[music] My
right hand is the one that can
kill
[Music]
You have Art's son,
you've been studying all the time without turning on the TV or computer Hey, it's less than
10 days until the national center
exam  Ah ah, the witnesses in my town are Yale
himself and
I'll do my best again